so people asking about green
infrastructure and bi green
infrastructure and we sometimes call it
natural capital that's kind of our wonky
term for using nature as an acid base
and you can contrast that with gray
infrastructure man-made infrastructure
there are so many instances now when we
can compare and contrast an investment
in nature green infrastructure versus an
investment in gray infrastructure one
example would be moister reefs we
learned we got stimulus money from
President Obama when we had the economic
crisis and it was really interesting
work that we did we showed that for 1
million dollars we could build one mile
of oyster reef in the Gulf it happens to
be that it costs about 1 million dollars
as well to build a my a mile of
first-rate first class seawall why does
this matter well in the Gulf there's
great concerns about exposure to storms
sea level rise erosion and so there's
widespread agreement that the Gulf
states need to do something about that
and kind of the preponderance of
thinking has been governments need to
invest in in sea walls and similar gray
infrastructure we now have really good
data that shows alternatively you can
vest in green infrastructure a new
oyster reef the oyster reef performs
just as well as providing at providing
protection from storms and sea level
rise and that basis it's a tie the
oyster reef cost about the same amount
of money 1 million dollars per mile
again it's a tie but after that the
oyster reef wins by a mile
for example the seawall we know like all
man-made infrastructure will depreciate
it will decline in value through wear
and tear the oyster reef if we take care
of it will more than hold its value it
might even appreciate in value over time
second the oyster reef is not just a
seawall it's an oyster reef it provides
habitat for oysters oysters clean water
moister shells ultimately crumble and
nourished the beach moister czar
obviously good for aquaculture the
fishing community moister habitat is
also habitat for other fish it's also
habitat for birds and it helps promote
tourism etc so it's a very concrete
sample pun intended of green
infrastructure outperforming gray